[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magacín informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre liliana
valencia aquí damos una mirada en
profundidad los hechos de actualidad de
la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
francia anunció su decisión de suspender
sus operaciones militares en mali esto
después de que la nación se viviera un
segundo golpe de estado en apenas nueve
meses además la unión africana y la
cedeao suspendieron al país y exigieron
que se restablezca un gobierno civil de
transición
la erupción del volcán gran gong o la
república democrática del congo dejó al
menos 350 mil desplazados según naciones
unidas una buena parte de ellos cruzó la
frontera hacia ruanda buscando ponerse a
salvo y nosotros esperan asistencia
humanitaria por parte de las autoridades
nacionales
y un nuevo secuestro masivo de
estudiantes se registró en el centro
norte de nigeria las autoridades
confirmaron que al menos 136 niños
fueron raptados por hombres armados y
ahora las autoridades intentan dar con
su paradero
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días francia
anunció su decisión de suspender las
operaciones militares conjuntas con
tropas locales en mali para luchar
contra los grupos yihadistas en la
región del sahel la medida se parte de
una serie de esfuerzos para presionar a
la junta militar que se tomó el poder y
pedir que se restaure el gobierno civil
de transición
esto después de que recientemente se
viviera en mali un segundo golpe de
estado en menos de un año a finales de
mayor ejército de mali arrestó al
presidente interino bandas o el primer
ministro en votar aún y los presionó a
renunciar
el coronel así vigo y está quien
encabezó el golpe de estado de agosto de
2020 y la revuelta de la semana pasada
fue declarado presidente además el
bloque regional de asia occidental
cedeao la unión africana suspendieron a
mali advirtiendo sobre posibles
sanciones y pidieron que se realicen
elecciones las que están programadas
para febrero de 2022
suspendido reintegrado y ahora
suspendido nuevamente mal y ya no forma
parte de la unión africana después de su
segundo golpe en nueve meses el anterior
perpetrado en agosto de 2020 llevó al
país a ser expulsado del bloque hasta
que nombró a los jefes de un gobierno de
transición liderado por civiles sin
embargo el presidente y el primer
ministro interino fueron depuestos por
el coronel así migoya quien fue
declarado presidente la semana pasada el
consejo pide un regreso sin obstáculos
transparente y rápido a la transición
liderada por civiles sobre la base de la
hoja de ruta de transición acordada para
malí de lo contrario el consejo no
dudará en imponer sanciones selectivas
la cedeao el bloque regional de áfrica
occidental también suspendió a mali
ambos grupos pidieron al país que
respete su compromiso para las
elecciones del próximo febrero pero el
asesor legal de guaita ha dicho que
necesitarán más tiempo de mayo para un
séptimo creo que objetivamente nueve
meses no son suficientes para hacer todo
el trabajo que tenemos que hacer
con traba en la unión africana y la
cedeao han pedido un primer ministro
civil que será el caso aunque aún no es
oficial se espera que el papel recaiga
en schoggl mahiga es uno de los líderes
del movimiento de oposición
m5 que organizó las manifestaciones del
año pasado antes del golpe de agosto
junto con la mayoría de la élite
política de mali mahiga está a favor del
diálogo con los yihadistas en el país
para tratar de sofocar una insurgencia
francia se ha opuesto durante mucho
tiempo a esta política y tiene más de
5000 soldados desplegados en todo el
sahel por ello ha amenazado con retirar
los de mali si persiste la inestabilidad
y hablamos ahora de la república
democrática del congo porque según
naciones unidas al menos 350.000
personas han resultado desplazadas está
la erupción del volcán giran gongo
mientras unos han huido desde la ciudad
de goma para resguardarse en el poblado
de sake otros han partido hacia la
vecina ruanda buscando empezar una nueva
vida
más de una cuarta parte de las personas
que han huido de la ciudad congoleña de
goma se encuentran ahora en la ciudad de
sake son alrededor de 350.000 las
personas desplazadas y los activistas
locales han comenzado a ayudarlos
mientras esperan más asistencia
humanitaria por eso mismo nos decimos a
nosotros mismos que no nos vamos a
cruzar de brazos nos juntamos hicimos un
grupo de gente para tratar de aportar
cada uno y traer esta primera asistencia
porque generalmente sabemos que las ongs
son lentas y el gobierno aún más miles
de otras personas desplazadas han
llegado a la vecina ruanda este es el
pueblo de uruguay
el volcán entró en erupción y los
temblores eran horribles por la noche no
podíamos dormir y durante el día las
casas simplemente colapsaban tamaño un
básico accionado busca la agencia de la
onu para los refugiados está
proporcionando alimentos y refugio a los
desplazados en ruanda
vimos la explosión de llamas del volcán
ir a gong oa las 12 de la noche
y el fuego estaba arrasando matando
gente destruyendo granjas y cultivos así
como casas y aldeas luego vimos a ruanda
para salvar nuestras vidas
pero la onu dice que la situación sigue
siendo crítica estima que los 350.000
evacuados necesitan ayuda de emergencia
y a pesar de que el volcán niria gongo
entró en erupción hace casi dos semanas
los funcionarios estiman que aún no es
seguro regresar a goma
y las fuerzas de seguridad de burkina
faso confirmaron la muerte de al menos
un centenar de personas en un ataque en
el norte del país
según el reporte oficial los hechos
ocurrieron en la localidad de solano
donde hombres armados dispararon y
quemaron viviendas las autoridades
catalogaron el ataque como el más
sangriento desde 2015 entretanto se
registró otro ataque armado en el
noreste de nigeria al menos 88 personas
fueron asesinadas en el estado de kevin
donde las autoridades aseguran haber
retomado el control no sé si va aseguran
que la masacre tuvo lugar el pasado
jueves 3 de julio
y seguimos en nigeria porque las
autoridades confirmaron un nuevo
secuestro masivo de estudiantes en el
centro norte del país
esta vez son 136 los estudiantes
raptados sin contar este último episodio
ya son al menos 730 los niños y
adolescentes que han sido secuestrados
en el país desde diciembre de 2020
una vez más los niños son víctimas de
secuestro masivo en nigeria
esta vez hombres armados raptaron a 136
estudiantes de una escuela islámica en
el estado de níger en el centro del país
así lo confirmó un funcionario del
gobierno federal
lo podemos confirmar con un total de 136
estudiantes fueron secuestrados a esto
siguió una sesión informativa sobre las
medidas que se están adoptando para la
liberación segura de los secuestrados en
nuestra última actualización revelamos
que el gobierno está haciendo esfuerzos
para identificar a los válidos y su
ubicación a través del trabajo combinado
de las agencias de seguridad
un grupo de hombres armados en
motocicletas atacó la ciudad de tejina
el gobierno estatal aseguró de estarse
comunicando con los padres de familia
para determinar el número exacto de
niños secuestrados el presidente de
nigeria muhammadu buhari dijo en un
comunicado que los agentes de seguridad
están buscando a los estudiantes también
confirmamos que el gobierno ha ordenado
a todos los internados en el área que se
suspendan las clases temporalmente
mientras se determina la razón por la
cual los bandidos atacaron la escuela
islámica el gobierno está en contacto
con algunos de los padres de los niños
secuestrados y se les ha asegurado el
regreso seguro de sus hijos permítanme
reiterar nuestra posición de no pagar
ningún tipo de rescate a ningún criminal
tú en escribirlo
en nigeria son cada vez más frecuentes
los ataques de bandas criminales que
realizan secuestros masivos para pedir
rescate durante el ocurrido de 2021 se
ha presentado una serie de redadas en
escuelas y universidades en el norte del
país en las que más de 800 estudiantes
han sido secuestrados la mayoría de
ellos han regresado con vida a sus
hogares
y también en nigeria el gobierno anunció
la suspensión indefinida de las
actividades de la red social 'twitter'
en el país lo hizo dos días después de
que el gigante estadounidense eliminara
una publicación del presidente mohammad
uruguay en la que amenazaba con castigar
a los separatistas regionales el fiscal
general del país aseguró que todo
ciudadano que rompa la prohibición será
perseguido mientras que los nigerianos
rechazaron la medida de tweets esta
mañana ni siquiera pude tuitear
es vergonzoso es vergonzoso que en todos
los estratos en todos los ámbitos de la
vida quieran quitarle todo a los
ciudadanos
vamos ahora la república centroafricana
porque miles de personas en su capital
banguí tienen que ingeniarse diferentes
maneras de conseguir agua para sus
necesidades diarias la falta de
infraestructura hace que el líquido
vital sea un privilegio en el país
centroafricano en el sexto distrito de
la capital centroafricana el agua no ha
salido de los grifos desde hace más de
cinco años
prince es estudiante en su familia ella
es la
de acarrear el agua el agua es vida y
estoy obligada a ir por ella para me
limpió la casa lavar los platos lavo la
ropa cocina esta tarde prince no tiene
ni las fuerzas ni el dinero para ir a
llenar los bidones cruza todo su barrio
hasta llegar al pozo más cercano a 500
metros de su casa al igual que prince a
miles de centros africanos se agrupan
delante de los pozos en todos los
barrios de la ciudad
en bani para obtener agua es necesario
salir a buscar la gustav un joven
estudiante de derecho administra el
punto de agua en su tiempo libre vende
el bidón de 20 litros a 25 francos sf a
lo que equivale a unos cuantos céntimos
de dólar y puede ganar hasta 8 dólares
al día es el pozo más barato del barrio
este pozo le permite a las personas
recortar trayectos y obtener agua en la
tiempo normal si miles de bañistas van a
los pozos cada día es porque el agua que
se bombea del gran río centroafricano el
ubangui ya no es suficiente pues la
capacidad de captación ha disminuido
considerablemente hasta tal punto que en
un momento estábamos cerca de expirar
solo ariza el banco africano de
desarrollo el fondo saudí y el banco
mundial financian nuevos equipamientos
para las odeca con varios millones de
dólares
pero mientras se espera su instalación
completa los habitantes de banguí deben
arreglárselas unos kilómetros más lejos
al borde de las colinas hay un
espectáculo fuera de lo común y es un
paso hacia la solución
aquí comienza una gran construcción de
50 pozos a lo largo de la ciudad
el costo un millón de euros financiado
por la unión europea en un mes se habrá
construido una veintena de pozos un
proyecto inédito de en banguí que
debería permitirles a más de cien mil
personas adicionales acceder a un agua
potable cerca de sus casas para final
del año y finalizamos este capítulo de
áfrica siete días con música de la
artista de dies nació en guinea
ecuatorial el único país de áfrica cuya
lengua oficial es el español y su nueva
canción titulada love you forever se
trata de un sencillo en solitario del
cantante de la reconocida agrupación
play seniors en el cual de latón a
tierna historia de amor con un vídeo
grabado en malabo la capital del país
desde allí divide se le envío un saludo
a la audiencia de áfrica siete días hola
mi gente soy bea' díez artista digno
teoría el único país de áfrica que habla
español quería presentar mi último
single love forever un tema con el que
doy un guiño a esas parejas que perduran
en el tiempo y que todavía tren de amor
así que lo dejo disponible en todas las
plataformas y gracias por estar allí
y justamente con la buena música de
divisas desde guinea ecuatorial'
despedimos este capítulo de áfrica siete
días pero antes los invitamos a visitar
nuestra página web www punto frente 4
punto com para ampliar la información de
américa latina y el mundo quédense con
nosotros esto es trans 24
[Música]